There's a complexity that comes from combinatorial problems.
We've seen that before.
In the cryptarithmetic problems ODD + ODD = EVEN.
We had these up to 10! different permutations of digits to assign,
and it was complex because we had to consider them all.
In the zebra puzzle we had 5!^5 combinations to consider.
It was complex because it took a long time to consider them all.
We came up with an optimization to consider a few of them by going one at a time.
For our pouring problem, we know there are 6 actions, 2 empties, 2 fills, and 2 pours.
The glasses are of size 4 and 9.
The goal is 6 oz.
I guess my question for you is how many combinations do we need?
For cryptarithmetic it was 10!. For zebra it was 5!^5.
For pouring is it 6^4, 6^(9-4), 6^6, or 6^9, or can't tell--none of the above?